on july 20th 50 years ago neil armstrong
and buzz aldrin first
set foot on the moon but before they
went there
they came here this is sedan crater and
it was
excavated by a nuclear bomb in 1962.
it's part of the nevada test site an
area of desert
bigger than rhode island located 70
miles northwest of las vegas
here the u.s performed 928
nuclear explosions and from 1965
they trained apollo astronauts like neil
armstrong and buzz aldrin
before their trips to the moon in the
following years
astronauts returned with spacesuit
mockups and tv cameras
they even tested out a mock-up of the
lunar roving vehicle
over a period of seven years eleven of
the twelve
men who would eventually walk on the
moon visited this site
so why would you bring apollo astronauts
to a nuclear bomb
test site that's what we're going to
find out
the obvious reason is because the moon
is covered in craters
so the astronauts needed experience in
cratered terrain
but there were other locations available
like behringer crater in arizona
claimed to be the site of a meteorite
impact though its origins were disputed
until the 1960s
in another part of arizona scientists
used conventional explosives
to recreate the exact pattern of craters
on the moon around the apollo 11 landing
site
now the astronauts did train at both of
these sites but the nevada test site
provided something
extra
[Applause]
the nevada test site was commissioned in
1951 as a place to test nuclear
explosions
the goal was not only to develop better
bombs but also to understand how
homes and household items could be made
to withstand a nuclear blast
three two one
zero
[Music]
a hundred tests were conducted above
ground before the nuclear test ban
treaty was signed in 1963.
it banned testing in the atmosphere
outer space
and underwater leaving only underground
testing
like the blast that formed sedan crater
a one meter wide hole was drilled down
into the ground right here 635
feet deep and that is where they located
a nuclear bomb it was a 104
kiloton device that means the energy
released was equivalent to
104 thousand tons of tnt
roughly eight times as big as the bomb
dropped on hiroshima
this close-up view was taken from a
ground station
three miles from ground zero the dome
rose to a height of 290 feet before it
vented
at three seconds it excavated
12 million tons of dirt and
rock forming what is the largest
man-made crater in north america
in fact it's the second biggest in the
world after chigon crater in russia
it's about 400 meters in diameter and
nearly 100 meters deep this was part of
an operation called
plowshare the united states is
conducting for the benefit of all
nations
a program it calls plowshare
with the idea being if you need to form
a big hole somewhere
let's say you're making a huge
construction project maybe a canal
could you use nuclear weapons to
excavate
that dirt enormous energy
relatively inexpensive compact and
easily transportable
this is the new power tool that
cloudshare would add to man's resources
of useful energy
to do jobs never before practical or
even possible
as you can see it's a pretty good
excavator but later they found out
that it's very hard to reduce the
contamination the radioactive
contamination that results
from a nuclear explosion and so the
operation was
effectively cancelled but what they had
created was the closest thing you can
get
to a meteorite impact crater and that
seems a bit weird because i mean
when i think about meteor impacts i
imagine
these sort of compressions of a big rock
coming in and pushing the dirt
out of the way but that's not actually
how it works
meteors are typically going incredibly
fast
like 10 or 20 kilometers per second
so when one strikes the ground it
creates an
incredibly hot dense high pressure
region
at the site of the impact this melts and
vaporizes
rock a shock wave traveling out from the
point of contact
transforms minerals due to the extreme
pressure
as the high pressure region decompresses
it creates what is
essentially a huge explosion and it is
this explosion that creates the crater
something you might notice
if you look at craters is they're almost
always circular
but if you think about it meteors impact
from all sorts of different angles
the reason you're seeing a circle is
because really
a meteor impact is an explosion
that is what forms the crater it's not
the impact otherwise you would see all
sorts of
weird oblong shaped craters nuclear
explosions are
so much like meteorite impacts that
craters
on this test site provided the
definitive evidence confirming that
behringer crater was
in fact the result of an impact
scientists compared
samples from both sites and found the
same shocked minerals
like coasite a shocked form of quartz
this mineral can only be formed under
the intense pressure
of a meteorite impact or a nuclear
explosion
further similarities with nuclear test
craters allowed scientists to estimate
that the energy of
impact was around 10 megatons that's the
size of a fairly big
thermonuclear detonation another
similarity is
in how these cratering events excavate
rock all of this
dirt got excavated out of here 12
million
tons and it was ejected out and over the
rim
and what actually happens in that
process is the layers of rock
actually get turned over at the rim it's
called inverted
stratigraphy this is a telltale sign
of meteorite impacts and nuclear
explosions
and it helped the astronauts know when
they collected samples on the moon
what to look for and where something i
was surprised to learn
was that apollo astronauts actually
spent 25 percent
or a full quarter of their final year
before blasting off to the moon
studying science visiting sites like
this one where they could learn
about geology about their rocks and
minerals and
the formations that they should look for
when they're on the moon
and i guess it makes sense because
these were scientific missions but they
weren't conducted by professional
scientists
by and large the apollo astronauts were
expert pilots
as apollo 11 blasted off the astronauts
were journeying
into the unknown literally
we knew so little about the moon like
how it formed what it was made of and
whether or not it was volcanically
active
when the apollo astronauts were on the
moon they actually used some of their
training from here
a lot of the rock samples got here the
hard rock samples have
what appear to be verticals in the
surface the astronauts
were really excited when they found the
rocks that they recognized
look at that look at the glimpse
in there guess what we just met i think
we found what we came for
yes sir in fact it was probably due to
their training here that they were
able to recognize those minerals and
those rocks
which were so important to bring back
and to learn not only about the moon's
formation but also about
our entire solar system and the
formation of all the planets
this is the actual moon dust
or lunar regolith collected by the
apollo 11 astronauts
i'm going to take a look at it under the
microscope now since the moon has
basically
no atmosphere all of this material had
never been exposed to oxygen
so there was some concern that once the
astronauts brought it back
into their spacecraft and introduced
some oxygen
that it would spontaneously catch fire
so
buzz recounts the story of how they were
ready to throw all the
samples out if that were to happen but
of course thankfully nothing did happen
when they brought those samples in and
repressurized the lunar module amongst
the dark
lunar dust that apollo 11 brought back
scientists identified
tiny flecks of a light-colored rock
which they
immediately identified as anorthocyte
and that was an important discovery
because it supported the theory that in
the past the moon was
entirely melted covered in a magma ocean
at least a hundred kilometers thick
so the idea goes that when an orthocyte
forms when the
minerals that make it up crystallize out
they are less dense than the magma
around them so they float to the surface
so the initial surface of the moon the
primordial surface of the moon would
have been made
of anorthocyte and then about a billion
years later
there was more volcanic activity on the
moon leading to lava flows
over these regions that are darker
called the mare
and you can see they have fewer craters
on them because
well they're younger so how do you get
anorthocyte
over here in the sea of tranquility well
that must have happened
through giant impacts in the highlands
which would have sprayed
ejecta all over the moon and so it got
mixed in
with the dark soil over here and brought
back by the astronauts
to my petri dish where i can look at it
today
but anorthocyte was just the tip of the
iceberg
inside all of these samples was a subtle
clue to how the moon
formed looking at the amounts of
different isotopes in a rock can tell
you where that rock came from
and when scientists analyzed the moon
rocks they found the same
isotopic abundances as in earth rocks
this is why we believe today that the
earth and moon
formed together from the same event a
giant
impact between planets four and a half
billion years ago
going to the moon and knowing what to
look for taught us not only how the moon
formed
but also how our earth formed
and all this from less than 400
kilograms of moon rock from the near
side of the moon
clearly there is still a lot to learn up
there and
personally i can't wait until we go back
who knows what unexpected discoveries
are waiting for us
when we return
hey this episode of veritasium was
supported by viewers like you
on patreon and by audible you know for
the last few weeks i have been
re-listening to
a man on the moon by andrew chaikin this
book
tells the extraordinary story of all of
the apollo missions
and in such gripping detail that it's
really hard to stop listening to it
i was listening in traffic on flights
even signing shade balls
yes listening to this book is what got
me through it and
there is no better place to listen than
audible just go to
audible.com veritasium or text
veritasium to 500 500
and browse their unmatched selection of
audio content
audible members get to choose three
titles every month
one audiobook plus two audible originals
that you can't hear anywhere else
on top of that members get access to
audio guided fitness programs and
meditation programs
and for a limited time amazon prime
members can start an audible membership
and save
30 total for the first three months
that's like getting three months for the
price of
one each month is just 4.95 per month
for the first three months and after
that
it's only 14.95 per month the offer is
valid from july 1st to the 31st
of 2019 so i really want to thank
audible for supporting me
and i want to thank you for watching
you